I think Obama is absolutely right to say
I'll talk to anyone and as he says he
doesn't mean that he's going to
katyPerry as he says he doesn't mean
he's going to parachute into a capital
drop in for tea of course he's going to
have a visit prepared but he understands
that that projects strengths rather than
weakness he understands that a really
secure nation is not afraid to talk to
people and is not is not absolutely
focused on shutting other people out and
not being willing to at least listen to
their point of view even if it's a
criminal regime we get more in terms of
the way the world sees us from hearing
their point of view from being willing
to have that conversation and then if
what they say or how they say it is
palpably aggressive or crazy then we've
taken the right step and we can say to
the rest of the world hey we tried we
listened this is not a regime that can
be reasoned with that is how a strong
leader acts that's true in my view
whether you're at the head of a school
or the head of a corporation or the head
of a country and Obama gets that so I
think that's the the in that sense
direct diplomacy makes a lot of sense he
also though has to be engaged in much
more direct diplomacy with our allies
and with our partners in different areas
the basic rule of persuasion is you have
to be willing to be persuaded to be able
to persuade others if you come in and
say look I'm going to persuade you I'm
not going to listen to what you have to
say you have to listen to what I'm going
to say it doesn't work it's a it's a
basic psychology it's it's a basic
tactic of negotiation you have to really
be willing to listen and to change your
own mind if you hope to change others
and we have not engaged in that kind of
conversation with countries around the
world even when we say you know where
we're going to engage we're going to
consult consulting as meant we go we
tell other nations what we've decided to
do and we say we hope you're with us we
need to be actually listening working on
what might be a common solution changing
our views letting other nations take the
lead where it's their region and they
have a direct stake telling them look
you go ahead will back you up but you
can shape the policy here we want to be
informed it's a different kind of
leadership it's a much more strategic
view of leadership and frankly it's a
view of leadership that is essential
given how much we've got on our player